there are three curses etc right so
incredible job from link [ __ ] shot it
to him on his third place we're gonna
check out the bracket real fast for you
guys Rand finalists blue god vs. you
toto and another run back of the run
back yeah so blue god with winter side
advantage that means that you total must
win two sets a best-of-five that being
said you know you Toto has been in this
position before he won standard Evo
you know he was looking great in that
he's been looking great all night
tonight he's even got you know some some
little pocket characters to help
moderate the matchups that are looking
at you to be tough now the last time
these two fought winners bracket um that
was like just a that was always bad
absolutely so having said that you know
you todos you know one thing that was
great was saddest you're getting to this
point he wasn't really dwell on the fact
that blue got defeated him he definitely
was taking it one match at a time and
he's here right here in the replays so
again blue got pretty much controlling
every pace of every part of the match
card bar was pretty much always flashing
red and he never cared right always
stepping at the right times caught him
this season I was a prediction with the
horizont to there he was like I know
he's gonna try to get away
mm-hmm that was Game one blue got
another close game in game number two
but huge lead in the last round as you
see yeah it just it just snowballed from
there like after the first game after
that that round right there it just it
has became too difficult for you told
her to compete and I mean so the thing
is is now we know that you Toto is
willing to go to the the secondaries the
tertiary is right um one of the things
that I like to talk about was in the
prior patch of Soulcalibur six went as
well was easily like emphatic I felt
like SAS Lommel had a 5/5 matchup with
the character I felt like he did very
very well and in fact one of the one of
the matches I like to cite to show that
off and this isn't just like a character
matchup thing it's also the player skill
of course was John Eddie versus blue God
Johnny versus blue god who's gonna close
his ass versus as well matches I've seen
in a long time maybe period right so if
you total goes towards that he may have
a much better leg up than if he goes
toward Faldo versus as well I almost
wonder right especially the way that the
first set winner I we talked about even
though we see
you Toto play exactly during this whole
China you seem like small weaknesses
like unwitnessed to use like so charged
offensively and certain things like this
right and I almost wonder if blue God is
just
he's like hyper focused on those small
things and it's just like no you don't
like you so charge so I know how to take
advantage of it you don't like to do
this so I not to take advantage of it
yeah you don't like to go ham and rain
zero you like to you know generally play
safe I don't take advantage of that and
it's almost like boo gods playing the
player matchup like it's your total a
little bit right yeah and I wonder if
you total sees that and if he rises that
he's got to change his way of thinking
as much as he has to consider whether he
should change characters or not it's
definitely hard to say because I mean
like you can tell that you thought oh
really like takes those things into
account quite a bit and that's why it
took him so long to figure out which
character he might play versus like
course um cuz he hovered over the Raph
you hovered over you know the as well
obviously you could we see the mirror
but no you're definitely right about
blue Vaughn picking apart the options
right the reason why he was able to get
away with so much aggression so much
just just pressure and pressure is
because he just keep pretty much to
refused to soul charge to get out right
and that doesn't work against a regular
fold or a regular fold don't like mash
is buttoned and does like strange things
that you have to watch out for it but
you total it's it's almost like in his
strength he becomes a little bit more
predictable then another vote though
would be and blue god you know she can't
play this the same way that he played
the witness promised to say the least
I'm sure it's gonna be like training
mode he's could be just gonna run over
him with setups I feel like you thought
her was probably thinking about it and I
don't know I don't see why he would play
the exact same he's probably thinking
about exactly what he needs to change up
again I'm worried that he'd probably
won't think about the meter at all to be
honest with you continuously looks like
we're seeing as well vs. volt oh well we
have blue God's gonna play as well like
I don't think there's any secret there's
it's a matter of what you total wants to
do right what is your total thing it's
gonna be a wrap I out okay looks like
it's gonna be wrapping out its resting
pit we have not seen this card to too
much during tournament he kind of he's
like hit or miss he was really great
early on when it was first released oh
god some changes just because
you know general like quality of life
changes that made him a little unpopular
since season two he's kind of back
people are trying to best to make it
work yeah well I I know that the
Japanese hold this character in very
very high regard to the point where he
may be the best one of the best for sure
America stance on it is that he's
definitely very good obviously yes I
don't I don't think that's with with any
sort of question I think that the system
made a big difference for him and the
issue with him is it's not that we don't
know that he's strong now it's that
because the rap guys all kind of you
know try to other guys for a while and
now they're all coming back to Ralph
it's gonna take a little while I think
for them to be comfortable you know when
you have when you get all the new the
new tools and stuff like that you it's
always gonna take you just a little bit
of time to get used to everything in the
proper positions because you have to not
only are you just like learning to use
the move itself but you're following
exactly when the move is most situations
and the range oh when I do it like this
it'll win in this matchup they're too
small stuff like this is somebody who
watches it Bob especially with a
character like Raphael man he got some
cool stuff in a prep stance though III
wonder if we're gonna actually see that
or if he's gonna switch off from Raphael
cuz I mean they were doing a button
check when we saw him clarify yes
there's a good chance
see that stands yeah yeah ha ha very
funny
you play as well I'm not I'm not even
fazed by a just Quran fine 300 sohcahtoa
points on the line the first place
that's right yes a lot of point the
prestige of evo Japan 2020 champion the
the large point lead that you're gonna
have at the very beginning at the Soul
Calibur World Tour you thought it would
be happy to win both you will Japan and
ego proper I'd solidify himself as
another one player yeah most definitely
I know he had a bit of a shake-up during
those world Invitational but I think
he's shown that he's back in rare form
and he's doing very very well sometimes
it just happens sometimes you have a
really off day and I guess maybe that
was the world Invitational for him
because this does not look like an off
day for him he's looking at smooth can
we get up whip up a blind I think my
eyes I don't know why though his eyes
he's just gonna pick as well place its I
expect that we're gonna see as well
versus boldo gonna get the handshake
here we go
control switching it up the crowd likes
it
alright so Rafael versus as well now
we're locked in officially this is the
first Rafael we're gonna be seeing here
in the top eight or just period it all
right and just like how this a slow-mo
was and to be but this is three out of
five and there is a lot of potential for
more character switching after this so
don't know if he's gonna do it but this
is it this is grand final to be both
Japan 2020 big star from early on a
little aggressive with the GI it's gonna
be aggressive from blue got to start out
right he's got to make sure that hey if
the question works just like it did
previously I'll just keep doing it first
and then if it doesn't he can change up
a style it's working out pretty well for
him right now is going for the mix-up to
join in the side throw a nice interrupt
right there
wrap always having one of the better
five A's and B's in terms of speed any
guess very quick and great long range
almost apply enough it auto cracks you
know when you do the follow up that was
a sheet he closed his swordplay is
careless
he's gonna do a bunch of those come down
and all we got the regr a great dance
with a mix up yet another lethal one
more powerful tool right if you do it
over and over again people may be like
okay you're gonna switch but but then
that allows you to continuously do it
that's right and then when they finally
when they finally start off high that's
when that great low axe becomes amazing
good block and she's backing off he's
got the advantage I don't need to make
myself into a I don't need to put myself
in a bad situation right he's already
gonna possibly guard break in here
fairly soon
you told us having a hard time trying to
he's getting a few pokes here in there
but he's have it all okay there at any
be he did not get the follow-up
unfortunately a boo God still in a
strong position this round man they're
both working card bar now whoa
now wasn't getting any pic its outside
of that though we'll see a lot of to a
break
forty three combo as you won't see if
you get them out that's gonna give him
acts dance to that means yeah he's got
it like crazy blue God has had probably
the strongest mix-up percentage this
entire time like the whole tournament so
charge from you Toto watch I guess now
that he's not playing ball though he's
willing uses meet her a little bit more
because he used it a lot more as well no
we haven't seen anything so charged
specific from him though that's true
he's got your red flashing card boy he
could just lose from anything basically
all he's gonna get seen here big damage
take this my love goodness I thought he
was alive still all right so the Raphael
pick up you Toto was okay but uh popping
nine dominant like he was hoping for the
thing is is like what if it's just one
of those situations where it wasn't warm
enough and it could possibly do better I
just I feel like if that plan was gonna
work I feel like Raphael was gonna run
away with that first game that's yeah
exactly it's like you're gonna run away
and then they're gonna have to adjust
your a new character oh and it's you're
struggling in the first game that gots a
little tougher for you total I think
yeah he hit that very much but not
quickness he thought you know maybe I
can make some adjustments it's okay
stuff like this happens
starting to open up the moonless a
little bit more but you know blue
goddess not is not you're not fooling
Freddie to extend this drinks you only
taking small down that was a good one an
excellent step right there that mix-up
yeah fifty fifty six punished very good
- you toto
we've got a did not get a real good that
could have been much worse like way and
it could have been much worse
yeah I thought he was gonna go over the
back throw but I guess on Oh Ethel even
worse Vince is all County get him on out
of there absolution you've got amazing
mix-up you totally is definitely trying
to predict whether it be a mid or low
neck sky far line there we go very very
smart right there from you toda tu RI
the pay blade muscle bus was not a clean
hit because remember her he interrupted
very very good from you Toto follow-ups
bus frames another he's just poking him
all my crock-pot - keeping way to get my
let's see no I got the walls mats - Wow
oh he tried to get even more you got
nice because the wall on this one do
goodbye
finishing it off so blue God looking at
a game Bert's you here this is it I'm
not gonna lie this is almost kind of
looking like the winners finals it's
like you guys partying doing whatever he
wants
mixing up and getting so many lethal
hits because you told us expecting a
load of call it Class G I know don't you
I back right there so much trouble X up
one more don't know what everyone that
kill BA and blue guy is a possibly about
to be able to turn boy he's looking real
good and your total is looking real
confused and he's he's doing that done
that laughs man my opponent is too
strong that's not a good Curtis Lecter
stage select let's see he's got a change
at this point I would imagine there's no
way that there's no way that he can lean
on the rock foil for three damages
Osvaldo as well he's gotta go hold
though I think at this point he's got a
lot of options available to him for sure
yeah as for the rules obviously moon-god
cannot switch characters he won it's
time
not in a hostile Oman he won he won
South East Asia majors over Shan Shan
with this pick okay
and I mean he he definitely looks pretty
good with that pick for sure but he's
not locked in and he's still thinking
about it it's not guaranteed we're out a
decision is on him
evolution champ you totally blew God
however has already beaten knew beside
in the mirror match to get to this point
so he's already shown that maybe he
might be one of the like he might
understand this mayor better than
everybody else I don't like this big
this pic says to me that he's not trying
to counteract as well he's just trying
to play the same game that you guys play
I guess we're gonna have to find out as
he is now completely leaned in on Azrael
for the rest of this set he has to win
three straight with this character or
that's over it's over for him and blue
God will be the champion tonight he's
looking real calm he's just you know
trying to breathe and everything like
that blue God looks like you said pretty
CDG's we got for a spotty photo
situation here possibly the last game if
you todo can't make something happen
right now right here nice talk five days
and stuff like that but the situation
again yeah it's time he goes for the law
webinars go yeah I think he just
understood the situation right he knew
what that teleport man
get the mid right there the one it comes
out oh okay
this gives them a chance to mix them up
afterwards oh not a clean hit thought oh
wow he's still in it you told her oh you
tried to hit buttons afterwards but blue
God understood I don't need to do
anything fancy I have the best move
available to me right now
oh he jumps that means that was not a
true bobble that hell didn't matter
though God will help me take that damage
for sure oh that was almost a really big
punch on the end try to mix them up off
that nose ice though the sword stance
comes out we got potential I'd be dead
right here let's see blue God to round
straight he is looking incredible
unstoppable right now and now he's also
absolute eagle just this this could be a
guess or die situation right now he's
trying to make it a guesser guy
situation is the sole job critical it's
gonna do a boatload he's putting him to
the check situation by putting as much
damage as possible on him right now look
at the damage
I don't know if he can even so charge
here he's soulless eyes for it see it
what can you do off of this this is it
you Toto's gotta make something happen
his final chance possibly almighty
amazing and is also the very first
champion in the Soul Calibur Walters
that was almost like
prediction like he checkmated all of his
opponents in the top a skill you Toto
twice winners finals and grand finals
he looked unstoppable about you as
everybody went through he defeated skill
with the greatest of ease you Toto was
nothing to him but the winners finals
was like a bull I think that was like
regular deer ranch so from every match
that I saw so far the hardest match for
blue god
whistling course that was that was the
from every match that I watched so far
not surprised I mean the two of them do
have a good amount of experience I guess
yeah exactly there's a lot of history
there dating back from many other Soul
Calibur it's not just this version of
the game
that's oh really lots of props up Luke
out of course 300 points as a part of
the sole copy Ward's or the first champ
of it and had to beat a standard
evolution champ you total so he was he
wasn't our finest scrubs it had to beat
champ skill as well so two champions
even and two of his demons at the same
time not just the two champions right so
you know obviously World invitation evil
you total wanted to make it happen to
get back to Evo Japan and win another
Evo he may just have to save it for
another time because blue God is coming
into this world to her to start who got
it looks like the clear favorite for a
lot of events coming